[Música]
se mantiene la expectativa en ecuador
por el pronunciamiento que pueda hacer
la autoridad electoral de ese país en
donde anunciará quien acompañará al
candidato andrés araus líder en la
votación en la segunda vuelta
presidencial ya q pérez y guillermo
lasso están en empate técnico tenemos
los detalles
la oposición allana eligió a un nuevo
presidente de transición al considerar
que el mandato del presidente juvenil
moix finalizó el pasado 7 de febrero la
decisión llega después del intento de
golpe de estado ante la negativa del
mandatario haitiano de abandonar el
poder y convocar a elecciones
el general líder de la junta militar que
tomó el poder en mi alma a través de un
golpe de estado reiteró que convocará a
elecciones en un año y también entregará
el poder a quien resulta triunfador en
esos comicios el militar indicó que
previo a las elecciones va a realizar
una extensa reforma al organismo
electoral de ese país
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález ya lo decíamos en titulares hay
expectativa en ecuador por el anuncio
que pueda hacer la autoridad electoral
de ese país en el que confirme quién
será o quiénes serán esos dos candidatos
que van a disputar la segunda vuelta
electoral en esas elecciones
presidenciales el próximo 11 de abril de
acuerdo con el más reciente conteo el
correísta andrés araus puntea en la
votación con el 32 puntos 17 por ciento
pero el segundo lugar es disputado por
un estrecho margen de voto por guillermo
lazo de la centroderecha con 19 puntos
59 por ciento de los votos y ya q pérez
ambientalista y también representante de
los pueblos indígenas y de una izquierda
un poco más moderada con el 19.85 por
ciento lo ubicaría en una segunda en una
virtual segunda posición vamos hasta
aquí todo en la capital ecuatoriana
hasta gustavo ortega corresponsal de
france 24 muy buenas tardes allí en
quito- gustavo cuéntenos cuál es el
último reporte que han dicho las
autoridades electorales de este país
hasta esta hora
sí muy buenas tardes para ti de
principios tales como tú has dicho hay
expectativas sobre todo porque en este
momento el consejero del órgano comicial
se encuentran reunidos para lo que sería
un próximo informe en las próximas horas
acá donde se ha establecido este centro
de cómputo al llegar a la espectativa
porque mientras que aquí se va a decidir
quién será el contendor del candidato
andrés zarautz en las inmediaciones de
este centro se encuentran reunidos
concentrados seguidores del candidato ya
q pérez quienes han decidido esperar
aquí han dicho que defenderán votos a
voto hasta conocer el resultado final
hasta el momento el 97 82 por ciento de
los votos escrutados y avanzar un
proceso ya es muy lento pero por qué
sucede esto hace algunos minutos también
podemos escuchar las declaraciones del
consejero josé cabrera y él dice que
bueno todavía faltan muchos muchas actas
por traer a la zona de los cómputos son
básicamente actas que se encuentran en
zonas de difícil acceso que debe primero
acercarse y posteriormente a tener todas
estas actas hay un proceso de
totalización hay un proceso de
impugnación hay un proceso
apelación posteriormente el tribunal
contencioso electoral deberá certificar
que no quedan recursos pendientes con
ninguna de las actas para luego de
finalizar todo este proceso dar un
informe definitivo al país gustavo que
se espera para el día de hoy en la
agenda de los candidatos y también una
vez sea nombrado ese esa dupla que va a
disputar esa segunda vuelta entonces
cómo van a ser la conformación de los
votos quien le dará votos a quien como
podría ser el escenario de cara a esa
segunda vuelta
pero básicamente esa es la expectativa
que se mantiene también el país lo
seguro es que va haber una segunda
vuelta electoral como va a ser con
solamente dos binomios electorales como
lo reza el código de la democracia en
este país cuando se realizará en 45 días
como establece también la norma
electoral se realizará el 11 abrir ahora
cómo van a hacer esas alianzas es lo que
se espera ninguno de los candidatos ha
dicho con quién va a negociar esa
segunda vuelta electoral por su parte
marlon santi quien representante del
movimiento político pachakutik aseguran
que ellos pelearán contra la derecha de
igual forma y leonidas iza que era uno
de los candidatos del movimiento
político que decidió declinar su
candidatura hubo ciertas divisiones que
bueno luego apoyaron al candidato y ya q
pérez aseguraron también que pelearán
contra la derecha así que no se
esperaría una asociación entre los
señores guillermo lasso si ya q pérez
podría suceder con las que izquierda es
democrática que va subiendo en la
totalización de los resultados santiago
gustavo muchas gracias por este reporte
desde la ciudad
de quito y muy atentos a cualquier
pronunciamiento y en el cn en la capital
ecuatoriana seguimos aquí en el
continente americano nos vamos hasta el
tee allí diferentes partidos de la
oposición nombraron al juez joseph mes
en jean louis como presidente en
transición a la oposición haitiana
considera que el pasado 7 de febrero
finalizó el mandato del presidente o ex
presidente para ello soy hub en el móvil
tal y como lo estipula el período
presidencial muy no convocó a elecciones
inmediatamente tampoco finalizó su
mandato e indicó que para final de este
año va a convocar a unas elecciones
generales este anuncio tiene lugar un
día después del intento de golpe de
estado denunciado por voice y que estuvo
acompañado también de multitudinarias
manifestaciones ciudadanas cote que que
planificación porque planeaban arrestar
al presidente
y una mamá
nacional planeaban invadir el palacio
para instalar un presidente provisional
que ya tenía su discurso preparado a
ella
y en otros temas el general mina aún
laing el líder de la junta militar que
tomó el poder en mianmar habló a los
ciudadanos por primera vez desde el
golpe de estado de la semana pasada en
su intervención el general reiteró que
va a convocar a unas elecciones en un
año y también entregará el poder al
ganador de esos comicios asimismo indicó
que habrá una reforma al órgano
legislativo y electoral de ese país
césar rojas nos cuenta más en el
siguiente informe el líder de la junta
militar que se tomó el gobierno en
mianmar hizo su primer pronunciamiento
público desde el golpe de estado que
comandó hace una semana dijo que la
comisión electoral debe ser reformada
que habrá elecciones y entregarán el
poder al ganador y cuando hayamos
completado el año de la ley de
emergencia procederemos bajo la
constitución de 2008 para realizar una
elección multipartidista y entregaremos
el poder
el que gane esa elección de acuerdo a
las reglas de nuestra democracia y su
declaración llegó al cierre del tercer
día de protestas contra la junta militar
en mianmar este lunes además de los
estudiantes y grupos de derechos humanos
en las calles de rangún la ciudad más
grande del país protestaron monjes
budistas los militares amenazaron con
usar munición letal si los manifestantes
cruzaban las líneas prohibidas
las manifestaciones llegan tras una
semana que parece una vuelta al pasado
el lunes primero de febrero los
militares declararon el estado de
emergencia por un año y se tomaron el
poder
dos días después trabajadores de 70
hospitales en el país detuvieron sus
actividades en señal de protesta y en
medio de una campaña de desobediencia
civil
[Música]
ese mismo 3 de febrero los militares
presentaron cargos en contra de la líder
aung sang suu kyi y el presidente wings
también bloquearon facebook y whatsapp
el viernes mientras la junta de tenía
win gain mano derecha de sus y los
profesores y algunos funcionarios del
estado se unían a los movimientos de
desobediencia civil
al día siguiente miles de personas se
tomaron las calles la junta bloqueó
twitter e instagram y ordenó apagar
todas las redes de internet se
instalaron el servicio el domingo pero
las redes sociales siguieron bloqueadas
este lunes el general a la cabeza de
mianmar no hizo mención alguna a la
líder birmana aún sancisi mientras
occidente sigue pidiendo su liberación
vamos hasta el continente africano al
menos 24 obreros murieron tras un
aparente cortocircuito en una fábrica
textil clandestina en la ciudad de
tánger en el norte de marruecos de
acuerdo con los reportes la fábrica
estaba localizada en el sótano de un
edificio residencial el cual sufrió una
filtración de agua por las fuertes
lluvias recientes el agua entró en
contacto con el cableado eléctrico de
las máquinas que no estaban
idealmente instalado y provocó este
cortocircuito
en otros temas fue reanudado el juicio
contra el primer ministro de israel
benjamin netanyahu quien es acusado por
presunta corrupción en diferentes
instancias el premier
asistió a la audiencia de un tribunal en
jerusalém en donde se declaró inocente
de los cargos de cohecho fraude y abuso
de confianza la defensa de netania o
argumentó que este proceso legal viola
la ley israelí dado que no fue
presentado un permiso escrito por el
fiscal general del estado
es todo por el momento en las noticias
de france 24 más información en la
página web france24 puntocom en las
redes sociales y en la app siga con
nosotros buenas tardes
[Música]